in some places they say it's caviar
when you change from mexico
it's not from fish but from the
escamoles ant in the
ant's egg which is very tasty afterwards
[Music]
my name is jose barrier islands
i work in the countryside
[  Music]
I am over 40 years old and the current
campuses
in the season are between March and April,
when it is the mixing season,
when the jarilla is already
blooming, it already has a yellow flower, that is when
the echelon begins
[Music] it is
very hard to look for them and find them
scratch
them sometimes you scratch them for many hours you ca
n't find them
[Music
] sometimes you have to scratch a meter you have
to scratch 23 meters long you don't know
exactly where the nip is
but we're going to do our best to
find it
you have to be in a hurry getting it out because
the screws go up more and more and they
bite not a web pickup
that sometimes doesn't give it a good one but
we are the means to get what
we want
because here is almost everything  we really know them
the city not many people who
know him more than anything are the
restaurants where he is more popular he is
like
me insects have existed for a
long time he is one of the
main ingredients of the food of
our prehispanics
[Music]
me  I am Josefina López Méndez and I am the
executive chef of the Chapulín restaurant.
Chapulín is really a restaurant that
pays homage to all the ingredients
of Mexican cuisine, always
working hand in hand with Mexican products and producers
and giving a lot of emphasis to
our Mexican products from all over the
Republic
.  he's a jerk when you consume him or he
really tastes like butter he tastes
like water the taste is very noble it's very
tenuous when you can bite a scan
all it really is as if he broke it's a
balloon and then it has water inside
like with little pieces there like  of dough
no we usually cook it with
epazote and onion which is a very
classic stew in all of mexico aco  We accompany
with guacamole with toast and others with
yellow corn and a little bit of
sheep's cheese so the scan all is how to
treat it as with slightly
stronger flavors but always respecting the flavor of
this watery and buttery one
that the flake has
[Music] well
I still knew my grandfather
but in the joy of knowing
him he was the first to come to this town
to teach them the step
and then my grandfather gave me potatoes and
I continued with that tradition
one says be in dad yes to my grandfather  he
liked it well why not because I'm not going
to follow that tradition of keeping it
out
and well right now my grandson I hope he
also learns from me so that this is
followed by the family family that
follows age what is not lost is that
tradition  that we have
[Music]
and